un centenar de agentes migratorios
mexicanos fueron desplegados en los
límites fronterizos con guatemala las
dos razones que dan las autoridades
hacen referencia al freno que quieren
dar a la propagación del cobi 19 y a los
migrantes que desean llegar a eeuu los
funcionarios fueron enviados a los
cruces informales conocidos como el
coyote palenque limón rojo armadillo y
cascajo entre otros por donde pasan los
extranjeros con destino al estado de
chiapas en méxico por donde se suele
traficar mercancía y pasan cientos de
migrantes a través de balsas que cruzan
el río suchiate ellos tiene los derechos
de de este lado pero qué vamos a hacer
policía militarizada y uso de drones
para viajar a los puntos de entrada son
las medidas más estrictas en esta
frontera y estarán en vigor hasta dentro
de un mes con la posibilidad de ser
renovadas
está vigente y está vigente la otra vez
aquí estuvieron también compañeros de
ellos mostrábamos nuestra tarjeta y nos
dejaban pasar porque tenemos el permiso
pero no ahora no nos quiere dejar pasar
por el momento quienes no cuenten con un
permiso migratorio no podrán cruzar a
méxico y solo lo podrán hacer a quienes
vayan a recibir tratamiento médico por
otra parte el secretario de seguridad
nacional estadounidense alejandro
mayorkas pidió este domingo tiempo para
reconstruir el sistema migratorio de
manera ordenada e instó a quienes estén
pensando en iniciar el viaje hacia la
frontera del país que no lo hagan por su
seguridad